So, in high school.
Yes.
Your superlative, if you will,
Yeah.
Was most likely to be-
Most likely to be a talk show host.
How cool is that?
(audience applauding)
Yup.
(chuckles)
I love that.
That was one of the first things I learned about you,
and I was like, "Oh my God,
we're gonna have so much in common."
Yeah, exactly.
Would you mind taking over?
I wouldn't mind at all.
Really?
(audience applauding)
Like, take over the whole show.
Yeah.
Well, all right.
Okay, so now we're gonna do a super fun addition,
hosted by Sam, of the "Final Five".
(audience applauding)
All right, I'm not asking the questions.
You're in the driver's seat.
You are the host of this show.
So, take it away.
Yeah.
Guys, I've got a great guest.
Drew Barrymore, everybody.
(audience applauding)
You already are better at this then me.
I'm not kidding.
Drew, look, I have never seen "ET".
Can you believe that?
(audience gasps)
I've never seen "ET"
Neither have my kids.
Yeah.
And they don't want to, I don't know why.
Well, it's classic, it's classic.
I feel, I've been too embarrassed to like,
now it's been so long, I've been embarrassed to sit down
and just watch it on my own,
but I have to.
But tell me in a sentence, how would you describe the movie
to someone who's never seen it?
Rad and surprisingly emotional.
Yeah, yeah.
Just-
(audience applauding)
I'd say that's rad.
So surprisingly emotional.
Drew, who do you think does the best impression of you?
Oh my gosh.
I'm lucky, there are these incredible women who,
like, Kristen Wiig does a great one.
Mh-hm.
Sarah Paulson does a great one.
Chloe Fineman.
Chloe Fineman does amazing.
Is kind of the raining queen right now, currently.
The "5O First Dates".
Yeah.
Oh, one of my favorites.
(audience applauding)
Rom-com, I love a rom-com,
so "50 First Dates" makes me cry every time.
It really does.
The end of that movie makes me cry.
What is one behind the scenes tidbit
from making that movie that you've never shared?
Cameron Diaz, not to name drop,
she came to visit in Hawaii and then she never left.
Oh.
So we got,
I had a hotel room and we got the one next door
and we had a common room and it became a party central
for the entire movie.
And we just had, well, we put a ping pong table in our room.
Oh.
And it was,
it was one of those moments that,
I'm not sure if I knew then that it would be
one of my favorite memories of life,
but I knew it was good.
And I tried to be present for all of it.
Yeah (Sam laughs)
Oh, that's terrific.
And our room really was party headquarters.
Yeah, of course.
Of course.
It was so fun.
(audience applauding)
(Sam chuckles)
Drew, I am obsessed with Batman,
I don't know if anybody knows that about me.
But if you could be a superhero, who would it be?
Usually you get the, "What superpower would you have?"
Think I'm gonna let you addend this.
You can make your own superhero
with a super power that you would like.
I would be Superman who could speed read.
Ooh, yes.
(audience applauding)
A speed-reading Superman
I love that.
All right.
Now, Drew, we talked about "50 First Dates".
You are the queen of rom-coms,
but what is your favorite rom-com of all time?
Probably "Dumb and Dumber".
Oh, yes, I love it.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Well, Drew
you're a wonderful guest.
And you're so good at that,
that you have suspended me and transcended.
I'm like, I think this is your show
and I should say thank you.
And I feel like, you know, you should read us out.
New episodes of "The After Party" debut every Friday,
on Apple TV+.
And we'll be right back.
Sam, you were so amazing.
(upbeat music)